la troisième particularité dans la
construction c'était le PM et ça pour le
coup pour avoir rencontré pratiquement
l'intégralité de mes prédécesseurs c'est
une nouveauté c'est que nous ne sommes
pas partis d'une courbe nous sommes
partis à la fois de quelques grands
retours d'expérience l'Ukraine mais pas
que l'Afrique et la lutte contre le
terrorisme ces dernières années mais pas
que regardez en face force et fragilité
notre modèle d'armée mais pas que et
surtout regarder évidemment les menaces
telles qu'elles pèse réellement sur la
nation française dans son ensemble pour
aujourd'hui mais aussi pour demain c'est
à dire en clair les menaces qu'on est
capable d'imaginer à l'horizon 2035 2040
peut-être au-delà mais enfin beaucoup
d'humidité aussi ne s'emparer de nous
dans la manière de construire cette
affaire ça veut dire qu'au fond les 413
milliards c'est un mur qu'on a construit
par le bas en regardant au fond
qu'est-ce qu'il faut réparer continuer à
réparer c'était le mot clé de la LPM
dans lequel nous avons que nous
connaissons encore aujourd'hui qui a été
voté par la législature précédente et
puis
et le quinquennat précédent et
évidemment de regarder un tout petit peu
quels sont nos besoins pour essayer de
se projeter je le dis puisque c'est
peut-être là un point de divergence que
je pourrais avoir avec certains
commentateurs ou même peut-être certains
rédacteurs c'est de nous comparer avec
l'Ukraine je pense qu'une puissance
dotée membre de l'OTAN à l'ouest en plus
du territoire de l'OTAN de prendre ceux
qui se passe in extenso en Ukraine comme
modèle de référence pour nos armées ou
pour notre sécurité collective présente
un biais intellectuel qui polluent
nécessairement la copie la France c'est
la France ne cherchons pas la comparer
avec d'autres pays et même d'ailleurs si
on devait la comparer à la
Grande-Bretagne autre puissance dotée
membre de l'OTAN la Grande-Bretagne n'a
pas la même relation avec les
territoires d'outre-mer on pourrait se
comparer avec l'Allemagne qui n'est pas
une puissance de thé bref donc je pense
que chaque situation sécuritaire à ses
particularités et que il ne faut pas
chercher la facilité et je crois que
même qui est un caractère absurde et je
l'avais dénoncé et je le refais au
niveau devant vous à dire que et si nous
étions dans la même situation que
l'Ukraine nous n'aurions que X jour pour
notre artillerie ou x jour ou x semaines
devant nous pour nos chars pardon mais
c'est refaire revivre des débats que
cette maison a pu connaître dans les
années 60 quand Pierre Messmer ou Michel
Debré venait défendre la force de frappe
et la nécessité de la force de frappe
devant cette maison donc je pense que
pour le coup il faut se projeter
autrement parlons de le dire sans être
trop patriote mais entre Français sur la
réalité aussi de ce qui est de ce qu'est
la France ça veut donc dire aussi qu'il
y a plein de menaces qui ne sont pas
couvertes évidemment par la dissuasion
par notre modèle d'armée tel qu'on le
connaît aujourd'hui parce que tout
simplement sous votre nucléaire des
espaces nouveaux de conflictualité je
vais y revenir se font jour c'est vrai
de l'espace c'est vrai les fonds
sous-marins c'est vrai du cyber j'aurai
l'occasion de le détailler dans un